[Music]  we called it the travel and it's arrival  changed us forever  eyes up Guardian you must push back the  darkness  guardians are fighting on earth and  beyond  join them six of us went down into the  pit in the end  all bowed before me we have slain his  brood  we have murdered his son and now the  taken King comes for us all  [Music]  [Music]  we thought we were indestructible  you're not brave have merely forgotten  the fear of death go  under light without the light  but we even Guardians any me  we should have been there  any last words I'm coming home  yes so this is to be a reckoning  [Music]  how long has its added silence watching  bass it seems those responsible for our  collapse are coming back  we've been waiting  [Music]  we are you are salvation  line between light and dark is so very  thin  do you know which side you're on  [Music]  besides should always be taken  even if it's the wrong side